♪
>> Judge Jeanine: ELON MUSK AT
TAKING HIS BATTLE FOR
FREE SPEECH RIGHT TO THE WORKERS
OF TWITTER, THE WORLD'S RICHEST
MAN WILL BE SPEAKING TO TWITTER
EMPLOYEES AT A TOWN HALL THIS
WEEK, THE FIRST TIME SINCE HE
AGREED TO A $44 BILLION BUYOUT.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT LIBERALS WHO
WORK THERE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
SABOTAGE ELON MUSK AND HIS PLANS
TO CRACK DOWN ON CENSORSHIP.
TWITTER EMPLOYEES PREVIOUSLY
COMPLAINED THAT HE RUINED THEIR
FOCUS WEEK.
VERY SAD, I TELL YOU, GREG.
VERY SAD FOR THESE TWITTER
EMPLOYEES.
ELON MUSK COMING IN UPPING THE
PRICE OF THE STOCK, AND THEY ARE
DISAPPOINTED.
DO YOU THINK THEY NEED A CRYING
ROOM?
>> Greg: HERE'S MY PREDICTION,
THE EMPLOYEE'S MOST ANGRY WILL
TALK ABOUT THE HYPOTHETICAL HARM
THEY EXPERIENCE FROM WORDS AND
IDEAS THAT THIS IS CREATING AN
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT, THAT'S WHY
THEY WANT TO BAN THE MADNESS AND
EXTREMES OF GENDER AND TRANS
ACTIVISM AND WHAT TEACHERS WERE
ACTUALLY TELLING THEIR KIDS IN
SCHOOLS, AND THAT FOR THEM THEY
THINK IS UNSAFE AND HARMFUL,
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY KIND OF
REVEALS SOME IDEOLOGIES.
SOMETHING IS AFOOT THOUGH.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT TWITTER,
IT'S ABOUT WHAT ELON MUSK IS
PART OF, AND MAY BE INSPIRING
OTHER COMPANIES TO DO THE SAME
THING, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
ARE ADULTS RETURNING FROM
VACATION TO TELL THE KIDS TO GO
UPSTAIRS AND EAT THEIR FREAKING
VEGETABLES.
LOOK AT NETFLIX PUTTING THEIR
FOOT DOWN.
NEWSPAPERS REMOVING THEIR
OPINIONS, WHILE BOTH FIRING THAT
ONE BAD MOUTHING WOKE-E.R.
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME AND I
THINK THAT WE ARE DISCOVERING
THAT THE TOXIC IDENTITY POLITICS
OF SHOWING UP AND BUBBLING UP IN
AREAS DID NOT DIE ON CAMPUS, IT
INFILTRATED THE REAL WORLD AND
IT IS MIGRATING.
AND I THINK THAT NOW WE ARE
FINALLY GETTING TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE STOPPING IT.
WE HAVE FOUND OUR LIMITS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
DANA, GREG MAKES A TERRIFIC
POINT, AND EMPLOYEES MAY ALSO
ASK ELON MUSK ABOUT TO THE
WORKPLACE CULTURE, THE OPTION TO
WORK FROM HOME.
>> Dana: THAT IS GOING TO GO
OVER REALLY WELL.
FIRST OF ALL, I HOPE THAT
ELON MUSK DID NOT SCHEDULE THIS
ON THE DAY OF REST FOR TWITTER
EMPLOYEES WHICH THEY ALSO GET
CALLED SUNDAY IN MOST PLACES.
HERE'S WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND
ALL OF THESE EMPLOYEES, KEEP AN
OPEN MIND.
HE HAS AN OPEN MIND, DO YOU HAVE
AN IDEA ON HOW YOU WANT TO
IMPROVE TWITTER?
IT INCLUDES CENSORING PEOPLE,
YES, THAT IS NOT GOING TO FLY,
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW, ELON MUSK
MIGHT LIKE YOUR IDEA OR HE MIGHT
SURPRISE YOU.
HE MIGHT TURN OUT TO BE THE BEST
BOSS YOU EVER HAD THEM SO I
WOULD LOVE TO BE A FLY ON THE
WALL.
>> Greg: THE FLY AGAIN, A LOT
OF FLIES ON YOUR WALL.
>> Judge Jeanine: GERALDO,
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> Geraldo: I THINK THE BIG
ISSUES OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
WHAT IS PERMISSIBLE AND THE
ANGLE OF TWITTER TAKES IN ALL
DADS WILL BE SUBORDINATE TO THE
ONLY ISSUE ON THE MINDS OF THOSE
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW THAT I BELIEVE
IS WHETHER OR NOT ELON MUSK WILL
GO THROUGH THE DEAL.
HE HAS BEEN --
I ALMOST USED A BAD WORD TO
DESCRIBE, HE HAS BEEN TEASING
THEM AND TEASING THEM AND GIVING
ME MORE ON YOUR BOTS --
>> Judge Jeanine: IS HE
ENTITLED TO THAT INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE AS MANY FOLLOWERS AS THEY
SAY THEY DO?
>> Geraldo: HE IS TOTALLY, AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO NERVOUS.
I BELIEVE THAT THE REAL ANXIETY
OF THESE PEOPLE ARE FEELING IS
NOT THAT THEIR FREE SPEECH WILL
BE INFRINGED, IT IS THAT HE
WON'T TAKE OVER TWITTER AND BE
WOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT HE
TEASED OF THEM AND SET THEM UP
AND NOW IT IS NOT AS VALUABLE AS
IT WAS BEFORE ELON MUSK ARRIVED
AND GAVE IT THAT JUICE.
BUT I THINK THAT THEY ARE MOSTLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR JOBS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY, JESSE, OF
TWITTER MISREPRESENTING
THEMSELVES?
>> Jesse: THERE IS A HIGH
PROBABILITY THAT IS THE CASE AND
HE WILL HAVE TO DO IS DUE
DILIGENCE AND SEE IF THEY ARE
BEING SALACIOUS OR NOT, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF GREG HAS HEARD
THIS PHRASE BEFORE, IT'S A
SAYING, YOU NEVER GET A SECOND
CHANCE TO MAKE A FIRST
IMPRESSION.
SO YOU SHOULD NOT GET ON THE
WRONG FOOT WITH YOUR BOSS WHO
HAPPENS TO BE A BILLIONAIRE AND
A GENIUS, SO DON'T GO OUT THERE
AND PEACOCK AROUND AND SHOW HOW
WOKE YOU ARE TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
MAY BE BE HUMBLE, TAKE A DEEP
BREATH COMING MIGHT ACTUALLY
LEARN SOMETHING AS DANA SAID
FROM ELON MUSK PAIRED WHEN I WAS
GIVEN A SEVEN I CALLED ALL THE
SMARTEST MOST SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE
IN THE TV BUSINESS.
>> Greg: YOU DID NOT CALL ME.
>> Geraldo: NOR I.
>> Dana: I DO NOT GET A CALL.
>> Jesse: WE ARE OFF ON THE
WRONG FOOT.
AND I ASKED THEM WHAT WAS YOUR
ADVICE, I CALLED PEOPLE OUTSIDE
THE BUSINESS, BOB CUSTIS, SPORTS
GUY, PROBABLY WILL RUIN HIS
REPUTATION THAT I AM ANNOUNCING
THAT A CALLED HIM.
AND THEY SAID LISTENING IS THE
KEY.
AND IF THESE NEW EMPLOYEES WOULD
JUST LISTEN TO THIS GUY, HE IS
ACTUALLY PRETTY INSPIRING.
SO JUST LISTEN TO THEM AND SEE
HOW IT GOES.
>> Greg: YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID I SAY?
I'M SORRY FOR I DON'T KNOW.
>> Geraldo: SOR